here now Ben Shapiro editor-in-chief of
daily wire comm and the host of the Ben
Shapiro election special which starts
this Sunday at 8 o'clock Eastern right
here on the Fox News Channel which we
are all looking forward to having been
with us through the midterm Ben good to
see you tonight thank you very much for
being here to see you talked a lot on
your podcast today yesterday about what
you see has a lot of injustice that
feels inherent in this in terms of how
this whole thing has been approached
there's a lot of questions that are
being raised tonight about who might
have sort of jumped into the fray to
help this woman and to get involved in
her case and what their motivations
might be and there's a story by Politico
later on later this afternoon which
suggested that a woman named Ricky
Seidman is advising her and of course
she's allowed to have anybody she wants
advise her it's a free country but it is
interesting to note that Ricky Seidman
also helped someone else in the past
let's watch on September 6
Ricky Siteman called me she told me that
she knew someone who worked on the
Senate Labor Committee James Bradley who
would have information it worked in the
areas of sex and sex discrimination and
that he would be able to give me some
indication of the law me think about
that bad well I mean obviously there is
a political attempt here I mean the fact
that the accuser is now going to a woman
who was working with Anita Hill in the
Clarence Thomas trial doesn't speak
highly of these sort of non partisan
element and in this whole case and
that's what's been so troubling whether
you believe the accused or whether you
don't believe the accuser the Democrats
have made it nearly impossible to just
look at this as a question of guilt or
innocence
it looks like a political smear there's
just no way around it the way the Dianne
Feinstein handled this she first saw a
letter July 30th shouldn't reveal it to
anyone else for six weeks and then
finally they come forward two days after
Brett Kavanaugh finally finishes his
hearings six seven days afterward that's
when we finally hear the entire story
when she first referred the story she
didn't actually give it the name of the
accuser shouldn't give what actually
happened the accusers still can't give a
date or a time as to when this happens
makes it incredibly difficult for Brett
Kavanaugh to even to
and himself and meanwhile he got
Democrats saying well we want to hear
her story and then the minute
Republicans say well why don't you just
bring her you know like in front of our
committees so we can hear her story then
Democrats say hey that's sexist it's
sexist to want to hear her story so if
they don't hear her story its sexism and
silencing her if they do hear her story
I'm cop they've offered her you know a
private anything she wants really you
know however she wants to convey her
information they've said they go to
California they want to make it as open
and accessible a process for her as they
can and they're in those those
negotiations tonight I'm just shocked
you know sort of given the history that
we've seen in these cases and you know
you've pointed out and I've pointed out
we don't know what happened nobody knows
what happened in this case and you know
obviously that's the most important
underlying factor of what's going on
here but I'm shocked when you look back
at like the Duke case or the UVA case
and some of these cases that have
unraveled that people are so willing to
jump in with their opinion not knowing
her or not knowing anything about the
actual facts watch some of this that was
released today in in support of the
accuser he should not be confirmed he
should not be confirmed he should not be
confirmed you and your testimony are
credible
you and your testimony are credible you
and your testimony you're credible
they'll leave
[Music]
we believe you fam and my gardener says
that she's not credible who the hell
cares what a bunch of celebrities
weren't in the room and haven't been
anywhere near that side of the country
for a while have to say about what
happened here I mean what exactly like
do they have to shed on any of this it
gets even more absurd than that we've
seen two interviews in the last 48 hours
from people who are in classes with
Christine Blasi Ford when she was back
in high school
saying they believed her story and then
when just specifically asked whether
they actually heard about this they say
no do they know anything about Brett
Kavanaugh no but they believe her story
because bad things happen to them
well that's not a standard as to whether
you know something bad happened in this
case the idea that justice truth and
guilt and innocence but these things can
be decided simply by appeal two men are
bad and women and must always be
believed it's absurd you have to have
some standard of evidence before you
destroy a man's life you at least have
to give him the chance to defend himself
Democrats are now saying things like if
he even defends himself he's insulting
the woman Annamarie cocked over a Wang
Kenan on MSNBC she suggested that it
doesn't really matter whether Brad
Kavanagh is guilty or and I said what
really matters is whether he feels this
woman's pain yeah well if you're Brett
Kavanaugh and a woman just accused you
in your opinion of sexually assaulting
you falsely sexually assaulting her
falsely are you really gonna be sitting
there thinking about her level of pain
are you gonna thinking be thinking I
need to defend myself I have daughters I
have a wife I have a life hey this is
all insanity and again it's
demonstrative of the fact that if we
really wanted to get to the truth of the
situation if Democrats really gave one
crap about this what Democrats would be
doing is putting this woman in front of
a hearing calling whatever witnesses
they could and then they would be
attempting to bolster her case they
wouldn't be hiding her and then
suggesting that any questions to be
asked are somehow undermining the
justice system man thank you
look forward to seeing you on Sunday
night good to see you